are you ready for some new overwatch  maps you might get your wish granted  before too long I'm Tony in this game  spot news update is in development  responding to a threat on the overwatch  forum director Jeff Kaplan talked about  the team's plans for more standard maps  aka those used in quick play and  competitive play he stated we currently  have three maps and development all past  the initial play testing phase that are  standard maps while something can always  change all three of those are looking  likely for a release this year we also  have a few other experiments going on  experiments is a vague word but Kaplan  did also mention three non-standard maps  the team was working on so be sure to  LIKE and subscribe to stay up to date on  those and for more discussion on  shooters check out the latest episode of  reboot all about how video games portray  war  [Music]  you  [Music]